Three incredible things just happened.
One, have a look at Adobe’s Firefly text
to image AI. The first version was not
bad. It was kinda usable. But good news,
Firefly 2 is already here,
and it is so much better.
Two, we can now control text to image AIs
using rich text. This seems like a crazy idea,
so I wonder what this is for? Why is this useful?
And three, from now on, we will not only
visualize, but even alter the world around us.
So first, Firefly 2. It can perform text to
image. This is where absolute magic happened.
Look how version two compares to version one. Not
even close. These go from a solid improvement,
to I am not even sure what is going on here
to, my goodness. Look. Now that is a huge
leap in capabilities for macro images,
I love this one. And just imagine what
we will be capable of just a couple more
papers down the line. I have to be honest,
I can’t even imagine. Can you? Also, their
gallery of results has also improved leaps
and bounds. And don’t forget, this tool is
being handed out to millions and millions
of people all around the world in
Photoshop and Adobe’s other tools.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
But sometimes, we don’t want to create an
entire image, sometimes we have an image
that is just right, but we would like to spice it
up with an underground city, waves, new clothes,
new planets, or this adorable thing. In these
cases, generative fill is going to be excellent.
Now, Photoshop has been used for decades now to
put text with all kinds of options into designs,
but here, they now introduced something
more exciting. Text effects. From now on,
you don’t need to be a proper artist to
create letters made out of gingerbread,
yarn, woven fabric, you name it.
They also showcased generative recolor. This
is for vector images, where the boundaries of
objects are known exactly from a text description.
This is a useful feature, but in my opinion this
can be done with traditional techniques too,
no AI is required. Not too impressive. But a
useful addition nonetheless. This video is not
sponsored by Adobe, we do not have any business
ties with them. This is why I can keep saying that
this is good, but this is not that impressive.
So all in all, solid techniques, not
necessarily the best text to image
on the market, we’ve seen better,
but the overall package is good,
and it is going to put in the hands
of millions and millions of artists.
Now, outside of Photoshop, when it comes
to text prompts, we have always used plain
text. But here is a crazy idea from a
really cool paper. So what if we could
use rich text effects to make our prompts, and
as a result, make our images more expressive.
Sounds great. But wait, is this really useful? I
mean, you can add some colorful letters here to
the hair, and the hair gets the appropriate
color, but we could do this anyway. Well,
if you are not a believer, check this
out. We can also use font styles,
which would then translate to artistic styles.
Hmm, I like it, now we are getting there. Or
if we want to make just one object pop, there we
go. But let’s go a bit crazier. Footnotes! This
allows us to prescribe more details about
an object without having to rewrite the
whole prompt. If we don’t like it, we change the
footnote and there we go. That’s a good one too.
But let’s go even crazier. Links. We can
now link to a particular image if we wish
to get a particular breed of dog, or a particular
product for a backpack for our images. And now,
something really simple, but really dreadful…I
mean powerful. You’ll see in a moment. Let’s
play with text size. So, would like pineapples on
your pizza, or would you like PINEAPPLES on your
pizza? You have to choose one. Choose wisely,
Fellow Scholars. You know what, being the good
Fellow Scholars you are, I’ll let you get away
with more pepperonis or mushrooms. I would
absolutely love to see this in future products.
Not the pineapple pizza, but text size. So good.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because three, we will now not only visualize,
but even alter the world around us. First, we
capture a few photos of a real-world scene,
then create a virtual copy of it. So far
so good, NERFs do that, we have seen lots
of works on this already. But here, step number
two, the geometry of the scene is then estimated,
and then the lighting is estimated too.
And now, we create a virtual object,
then put it into this scene, and, oh my,
that metal basket will actually reflect
the light in the scene properly, and will cast a
beautiful shadow too. And it works elsewhere too,
reflections and shadows appear as
they should. What a wonderful paper!
And these objects can also be a part of a
simulation in a virtual world. That really
gets my mind going. This way, we could
capture a real-world place around us,
and start playing with it as if it were a video
game. Or insert ourselves into a virtual world,
train self-driving cars safely within
a simulation that is a copy of the real
world, you name it. Now, for this
to be really useful, the quality
of the results would need to improve a
bit, but the concept is now out there.
However, this is still an incredibly potent
concept. Why? Well, you Fellow Scholars know
very well that one of my favorite phenomena in
research is sim2real. What is that? Sim2real is
when we would like to train a robot for something
in the real world, but when starting out,
this little AI is not doing very well at first.
It might fail a great deal before it starts to
be competent at its job. Take self-driving for
example. Or even a vacuum-cleaning robot. Now
imagine that we can create a computer simulation,
and they would train in this simulation, safely,
and my other favorite, efficiently. You see,
one second in real life is one second. However,
with a powerful computer, that same one second
in real life can be used to simulate hours,
or even days of progress. If we wait just a bit,
we might get a masterful AI that has trained
essentially for years and years. And here, we add
a twist to it. What if the virtual world is based
on the real world? We can scan the real world, and
create a simulated video game from it. With that,
now, these AIs are able to train in the real
world, yet, they do it safely and efficiently.
And with this new paper, add another twist.
We have the real world and now we can even
alter it. We can create scenarios that would
normally be almost impossible in the real world,
and the AI will be able to train on
it for years and years. I love it.
And just imagine what we will be capable of
just two more papers down the
line. What a time to be alive!